SPEAKER: So I promised
a demo of App Engine
in action taking load.
So-- oops-- there's
my Kubernetes app.
It decided to load.
OK.
So I have here a set of 10 VMs--
Compute Engine VMs.
And they're going
to hit that URL.
Please-- you can hit the URL.
Don't hit that URL.
No, no.
Don't, because you'll break
the whole-- like, from cold,
we're going to see
how App Engine scales.
So you can hit it after
I'm done with the demo,
if that's your thing.
So I'm going to go ahead
and run one make command.
And I'll explain what I'm doing.
I'm instructing
each one of my VMs
to send 1,000 hits at that
URL and to do it concurrently
at 50 apiece--
so a 500 QPS query.
So I'm going to run that.
I'm going to switch
back over here.
Someone hit the URL!
Someone did it!
That's all right.
You'll still see some magic.
So in a moment,
they're going to see,
as soon as Compute
Engine gets the traffic
and starts sending it,
they start bouncing.
And then it's App
Engine spinning up
instances of my
application in order
to handle the load
that's coming in.
And basically what will happen
is each instance can handle
a certain amount of traffic
at once, and then say,
hey, I'm a little pegged.
And we'll start spitting up
more instances to take it.
That's how quickly we
spit up instances in order
to deal with your traffic.
And that's why the
whole scale to 0
is awesome, because it quickly
responds when you have traffic.
But then, when we
don't have traffic,
it starts spinning
down instances.
And three of you--
your queues-- three of you--
four!
All right.
Well, now I don't care.
Now, you can just ping
it away all you want.
And you can see the
numbers go up in real time.
Yeah.
Yeah, you're really doing that.
You're really hitting the URL.
[LAUGHTER]
Oh, all right!
I've challenged people there.
They're feeling feisty.
So that's just a quick demo
of what App Engine can do.